or except i did howie's recently which
was weird and interesting too oh you
went to howie's studio thing dude that
was i know so howie's such a trip
because he shows you
things that you don't want to see
this thing i did see it on twitter yeah
i'm sorry i'm on tick tock yeah what's a
pr what happened to howie okay so okay
go ahead ethan yeah you could tell you
could i don't want to i don't know well
uh he showed his prolapse anus on
tickets well not his or her april lapsed
anus on tv are you sure it wasn't his
no if it was his
no uh
we got to ask him if yeah yeah so
prolapse in is i'm i'll show you if you
want a little audio yeah yeah this okay
but the back story is funny because okay
i did a show a couple weeks ago and he
was so paranoid the whole time because
he was like you're so out of control and
pc and he's been super nervous about
things i was saying because he's like
america's got talent judge and he's like
super clean and so
that was like the whole thing between us
was i was kept saying stuff and making
him uncomfortable and he's like wow this
guy's crazy and then a week later
how we post what is arguably the most
[ __ ] insane thing that anyone's ever
seen on tick tock and people were like
traumatized he traumatized people it got
deleted
and then there was like a whole
ecosystem of people on tick tock being
like did anyone else see what the [ __ ]
howie mandel posted and now it's a whole
meme but let me show you
let me show you because i saved all of
them because i knew this would happen
but let me just show you what okay let
me i'll go to you yeah yeah yeah here
here's the original okay look at this
[ __ ]
how do you describe that
and people are memeing how we like
putting their own stuff in right yeah
yeah so yeah
dude and then because it's like he's
it's somebody sitting on a deep dish
pizza
you're like you know i mean like a thick
ass chicago holy prolapse like grass
style that's wild and so then everyone's
like yo what the [ __ ] how we did and so
now that got removed but what we've been
doing because i wanted to live forever
is i cut his head out so he goes did any
is this because of covet and i have one
going right now that has 8 million views
that i just posted last night here it is
so this is the new format
[Laughter]
i can promise you bobby doesn't know who
that is it's james charles james yeah
but that's but so now a guy right with
this big um areola so we've been posting
this now because we don't want it to die
so we did it we did it in a green screen
yeah
that's amazing so we're going to do a
competition on our show
on friday or next week although we do
the best how we yeah prolapse anus uh
tribute what do you think of howie
mandel
great guy
funny great
amazing intimidated the first time you
met him
no no no okay but it was really
interesting because he followed we met
we saw him in malibu
with his daughter yeah i was with my
kids and ila and we were playing in this
playground there this nice park in
malibu and i said oh look it's howie
mandel
and then we were like okay so i'm gonna
go we walked to our car and he followed
us dude oh so he knew you he chased us
down with his daughter and said hey will
you come on my podcast wow
i was like wow some respect from howie
but so i went on there
and we had a really good time yeah yeah
i've done it several times but i love
his whole family but um
you know there's something
you're crying no no no i just feel juicy
we're homies now
you know how we next yeah oh no i love
him but here's the thing out of all
those old school dudes that like i grew
up watching
he's got to be
the nicest one out of auto yeah he's a
sweet deep the rest of them are like
kind of weird with me they're um
they'll go oh there's the naked guy oh
to me or whatever they'll just do a
backhanded respect right and then
they'll move on oh they'll say my name
or whatever but like
how it was always even when i was on med
tv and i asked him to do a sketch
he would just jumped on it you know i
mean he didn't need to do it in fact
louie anderson did the same thing like
you know um
but like yeah he's just one of those
guys that like i've always wanted you
can just feel his heart and go oh he's
just a good guy the class act yeah but
you know i invited him i said how you
gotta come on the show
and talk about the prolapsed anus thing
and he says listen ethan i'm laying low
on the prolapse
really yeah and wow i said howie this
gives a big opportunity for you we had a
viral moment
let's talk shop but he's langlo
is there anyone that you would have on a
guest that a guest that would be like
that you're a fan of that you'd be
nervous to have one person i had on that
i was really nervous to have one was tim
heidecker
oh which is like kind of it's funny but
like he's the reason i ever started
making comedy right i just looked up to
him so much but he did your show yeah
and he's super nice and awesome oh
that's cool it was it was years ago when
to be on and then bill burr obviously
destroyed me for two years because it
was such a train wreck interview yeah
what